if trump's not holding on in wisconsin
and michigan where the polling looks
very bad for him
he must go five for five in these states
the suburbs around charlotte as well the
suburbs around winston-salem
the president at the moment is is
turning two to one over joe biden
what's that tell us so turns out cable
news's election map guys were the
breakout stars of election night
yeah you watched them i watched them
they crushed it the other thing to
remember here this is a stripe in
nebraska because there's a congressional
district in omaha
yeah like msnbc's steve karnacki who
just hours into tuesday night's coverage
started trending in the us
on twitter yes i'm serious
why you might ask because the guy legit
navigated that touch screen electoral
map like a boss
we're going to get numbers from florida
tonight we're going to get a lot of
numbers from north carolina
from georgia from ohio from texas but
honestly it was this moment where he was
so in the zone he didn't even realize he
was live on tv
that did it for me you guys fans sent
steve
so much love online that he even shot a
little video to say
thanks on wednesday well you may not
recognize me there's no
giant touchscreen behind me but steve
kornacki here and i just wanted to say i
saw after i finally uh left the studio
uh all these incredibly you know kind
and
friendly and nice messages everybody
had on social media there i just wanted
to say thank you
no steve thank you this is how
far this state and this county has moved
then there was bill hemmer reporting for
fox news
and let's just say he too got a lot of
love from fans on twitter
one user wrote quote i'm only watching
fox because i like bill hemmer and how
he works the board
while another tweeted who are these
talking heads on fox
let bill hammer show the board geez
56 percent from 2012 barack obama
just come to this year and he's going to
easily win
this county and of course there's john
king
the man the myth the cnn legend
arizona out west is in play two reasons
the president is unpopular there just as
he is nationally people had a whole lot
to say about the anchor and his
commentary on the race throughout the
night
specifically the catchphrase it's fun
yeah john might have been the only
person on the planet to call
election night fun and the whole thing
really stressed people out
mainly because he just kept saying it
one twitter user wrote quote whenever i
hear john king say
this is fun i imagine this god i love
the internet
another echoed that sentiment writing
john king
this is fun everyone else then there was
this inventive idea drinking game take a
shot
every time john king says this is why
elections are fun
inventive but also don't because he said
it
a lot something else he said a lot big
dump
bizzy phillips hit up twitter to react
writing john king just said
and i quote sometimes you get a big dump
and it changes everything
and honestly yes john king sometimes it
does
while another twitter user wrote john
king keeps saying
big dump something that i personally
feel coming
anyway back to that fun jon had a little
fun with a fan who tweeted that they
were on their way to cnn headquarters to
make sure he was doing okay
after a long night of work and john he
responded writing
let us know how you take your coffee